hello YouTube chests lovers in my
friends this is grunge in here and today
I'm going to show you a trap exists in
park or the modern defense now the move
orders can be like this so white place
efore and the general response can be
either d6 or g6 either way they can be a
transposition so here in this game my
opponent plays g6 and the usual line
goes like this so white plays d4 d 693
Bishop g7 and here white plays Knight f3
now the system from the white is known
as a classical system and sometimes it
is also known as a 150 attack now before
we look at the trap let me tell you what
are the plants from the both the side if
you know about the park of the modern
defense then you know that the general
plan for the black will be this night
we'll come to the f6 and then black will
castle on the Kings side and then later
stages it will throw the spawns on the
Queen side and try to attack white on
the Queen side there is a general plan
for the black now what will be the
general plan for the white here now here
I recommend you should go for the 150
attack and layout will be like this so
here most likely white will play this
Bishop to e3 the screen will go to d2
and this Bishop will go to d3 and then
depending on how black has responded
white can choose either go on the Kings
side or in some scenario where if white
play wipe once to play aggressive then
it can go to the queen side and let me
tell you exactly where our trap lies
Ultra applies where black does not
attack the white center and black play
moves such as c6 now you can see if the
black has played moves such as c5 or the
e5 then I recommend you follow a plan
with castling on the Kings side but if
it plays somewhat passively it does not
attack the center then I strongly
recommend you look forward forward trap
so in this game my opponent plays c6 and
I responded with our usual plan so I
played Bishop e3 he responded with
Knight d7 I played Queen d2 he played
Queen c7 by the way this is the one of
the theory section of the park of the
modern defense where
black is looking forward for this if I
push for the right moment and here I
played again as per our 150 attack
theory I played Bishop d3 and here the
most general response or as per the
theory the move is Knight f6 and if your
opponent is going to play this line then
I suggest here now and only now you
commit the King side attack starting
with the move Bishop to at six now the
most logical response of the black will
be Kesling and not only now you play h4
now in this game because I was attacking
on his King side it's very logical that
black will attack the white on the Queen
side because that's where most likely
the White King will go and that's why in
this game my opponent plays b5 and here
comes our first little and very cute
trap which is h-file now you can see by
arrows what are the plans for the white
is white we simply likes to capture that
pawn and then he would like to capture
the bishop and then Queen will come to
that 6 and if that has been allowed then
white will have a very nice attacking
game so somehow black has to response to
this h5
I can't believe that many people even
people over 2,000 plus has completely
overlooked this trap and goes like this
so especially this happens in blitz or
even in bullet game and
black sometimes play this move Knight
takes H fire and wondering what exactly
happening and now comes our very amazing
tactics or our first cue trap I give you
a few seconds can you identify a very
good more here
okay I hope you identify this move rook
takes and now if black will take the
rook then unstoppable maid is there and
what is black is doing about this bishop
it cannot be protected anymore and the
worst part is it leads to the checkmate
so that is a very small and cute trap
exist in this line and up till now
probably I have won probably around 10
to 11 games like this anyways if your
opponent is good enough he will probably
realize this and in this game my
opponent decide to play this move so he
played before counter attacking my
knight and here our main trap exists so
here we will play this move so H cross
g6 and now there are a few options for
the black but the most obvious one is
the capturing this night because it's
not only capture of piece right now it's
also attacking the Queen so why has to
play very very accurately and here comes
a move she cross at seven now here black
has a two response
now if opponent King runs away like this
King goes to h8 then the very simple
mating attack is like this so first of
all grab this Bishop the check force
reply and then you give this check by
the Queen post reply Black has to
capture and now you give this check and
after the King goes to f8 this is mating
- this is a checkmate
so that cannot be possible so
black has to forcefully capture this
pawn so Knight cross at seven and now I
give you a few seconds can you find a
very good law over here okay the amazing
movers B cross C three
so only thing white has did is to
capture the pole which was attacked the
Queen and now it's very simple plan is
for the white is to capture the bishop
and then play the Queen to f6 and how
the hair on the earth black will stop
that plan the answer is no cannot after
a one-minute thinking in this game
my opponent come out with the only move
and that move has been suggested by
phrase which is Fi but still it leads to
disaster because after Bishop takes King
takes Queen check King goes to f7 then I
played Queen h4 check stopping King to
run away to e8
and once the kink arrived at f6 I take
this ball and then after this move I
capture the night and then this is
simple checkmate so this is one good
trap exist in the park and modern
defense I strongly recommend this move
order only if your opponent playing very
passively right best of luck for playing
this trap and I'll meet you soon bye